here's a random day in my life as a
farmer i started by cleaning my room and
then replied to some emails from
customers and got some chicken thawing
for dinner from the freezer before
making a super fast breakfast of eggs
and toast
i added some green onions and cheese to
this to just make it more flavorful and
it's super quick and delicious
morning chores then began and i drove
down to our shop to pack the curbside
pickup orders for the day which i set
out by our farm store for pickup
after that i fed and watered the chicks
in our brooder which are just over one
week old and stay in here as they need
the heat lamps to survive
[Music]
naomi just got back from feeding our
laying hens with bailey so we both
filled four buckets of pig feed for our
16 pigs and then drove out to our north
woods they all came over to see us when
we arrived which is so cute and we fold
up their theater i gave them lots of
scratches which they love
and check to make sure their electric
wire was on and hot and that they were
happy and content before leaving
we then went back to our shop and filled
five buckets of feed for our five week
old meat chickens we brought these out
to our east pasture to their mobile
prairie schooner and filled their
feeders and made sure that they had
water and were also content next on the
list was moving our flock of sheep
naomi and i set up their new area with
electric netting and let them in their
new area and then move their pen and
water
and turn the fence on to keep them in
and predators out as the last step
back at our shop naomi and i then packed
all the orders that will be shipped out
today as thursday is our home delivery
day
and we had leftover tacos
and we drove and dropped off all the
orders to be shipped out same day and
as soon as i got back i filmed some
footage
to edit for our customers and ended up
just sitting with the pigs as
they're honestly pretty fun to watch
after that i started dinner and decided
to make something we never eat which
turned into homemade chips and fried
chicken with green salad
definitely an indulgence but pretty
amazing
after dinner i brushed our dog bailey as
she's been shedding a lot and it's been
on my list and then the last thing of
the day was some formatting i had to do
and that's it